i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
porque nos quejamos
porque lo hemos aprendido
por hábito
porque tendemos a ser pesimistas
porque somos perfeccionistas y exigentes
por falta de empatía
porque nos contagiamos de otros o
simplemente por tener un tema de qué
hablar
en abril de 2016 a través de redes
sociales en cuenca compartíamos fotos
del estrago causado por el terremoto en
manabí
el avión que había salido fuera de pista
en el aeropuerto
y de las calles rotas por la
construcción por las vías para el
tranvía
cualquier persona del ecuador o de otro
país que veía las fotos y videos que
publicábamos podían pensar que la ciudad
entera
estaba destruida
inclusive algunos políticos la
utilizaban para hacer campaña en contra
de las autoridades municipales
nadie absolutamente nadie medía el
tremendo daño que le estábamos causando
a la imagen de nuestra ciudad
el 5 de junio a través de una
publicación en facebook pido que
en vez de quejarnos desde la comodidad
de nuestros hogares entremos en acción
y en ese post decía
escucho a las personas diciendo que hay
que salir a las calles salir a las
calles para que para quejarnos para
seguir dañando la reputación de nuestra
ciudad
soy hotelero-gastronómico y trabajo
desde los 13 años
durante mi trayectoria puedo decir que
mi mayor aliada ha sido la queja de mis
huéspedes
y lo que he aprendido a hacer con cada
queja es a transformarla en una
fortaleza
mientras trabajaba en uno de los mejores
hoteles de mar de plata argentina
un día sucedió algo que me hizo poner
especial atención a la queja
por accidente una salón era nueva riego
un plato de ravioles con salsa pomodoro
en el pantalón de un huésped justo aquí
de la desesperación se sigue agarrado
los ravioles con la mano y los volvió a
poner en el plato
imagínense la situación la esposa estaba
frenética el señor más aún se paró
furioso y se dirigió a la habitación
para cambiarse el pantalón
mientras tanto nosotros intentamos
calmar a la esposa el imposible estaba
demasiado molesta pasaron los minutos el
huésped regresó reinicio su cena terminó
su cena y se fue nuevamente a la
habitación pero cuando llegó a la
habitación encontró el pantalón en
perfecto estado una botella de champán
frutillas y uvas con chocolates y una
carta de disculpas de nuestro gerente de
alimentos y bebidas
para sintetizar les cuento que ese
huésped es uno de los más fieles de ese
hotel
desde mi experiencia personal y
profesional he podido percibir que la
queja es un regalo
y lo que he aprendido a hacer con ella
es transformarla en una solución
la queja es el resultado de algo que te
está incomodando el ejemplo de cuando
sales de la escuela de manejo e inicias
a conducir y es el ejemplo típico te
enseñaron a mantener tu distancia a
respetar el carril utilizar las
direccionales rebasar por la izquierda
al principio casi todo te estresa
te quejas por el que se cruza porque no
utiliza las direccionales porque te
rebasa por la derecha todo el tiempo te
quejas y es normal es porque no estás de
acuerdo con esa realidad
ahora qué es lo que pasa cuando te
acostumbras
en ese momento deja de quejarte el
estímulo ya no te afecta
es algo normal para ti y en ese momento
eres parte de la queja
por eso lo importante es darse cuenta
del proceso
cuando percibes un estímulo y te hace
sentir incómodo lo más probable es que
te quejes esas quejas pueden ser hacia
fuera o hacia adentro pero cuidado esas
quejas internas repetitivas generan
estados de depresión y en definitiva te
hace daño a ti ya los que te rodean
por eso
si quieres ser más saludable desde el
punto de vista físico y psíquico haz
algo con esa queja
lo mejor es tomar la energía de esa
queja fresca la cual realmente puede ser
un factor de cambio
normalmente nos quejamos en el lugar
equivocado
y por supuesto no sirve de nada por
ejemplo si tienes un problema en un
restaurante no te quejes con la persona
que está frente tuyo fíjate con el salón
ero con el maître con el chef pon tu
crítica en una carta y eso va a ser más
útil para todos
he aprendido a manejar la queja en mi
entorno de trabajo y ahora me ha tocado
manejarla en mi ciudad actual y hemos
encontrado una fórmula muy sencilla para
gestionarla
queja más acción igual a resultados
en junio de 2016 cuando nos quejábamos
por la construcción de las vías para el
tranvía y el descuido en la ciudad con
un grupo de amigos salimos a limpiar las
calles pintamos los parterres pintamos
las chirimoyas que dividen las avenidas
cortamos la maleza en los lugares de
exposición turística y el resultado fue
que las empresas municipales entraron en
acción y realizaban los trabajos que
nosotros realizamos pero obviamente con
las maquinarias que nosotros no
poseíamos
en abril de 2016 cuando sucedió el
terremoto en manabí las quejas de esos
días eran de que los recursos que se
generaban no eran entregado a tiempo ni
de manera adecuada con otro grupo de
amigos decidimos recolectar 60 toneladas
de juguetes alimentos y otras
necesidades para los niños y las
entregamos de manera personal
el 20 de abril de 2017 frente a que no
recibíamos un informe oficial de lo que
había sucedido con el avión en el
aeropuerto y de lo que se escuchaba de
una cancelación definitiva del vuelo
cuenca guayaquil cuenca de una de las
dos aerolíneas que vuelan la ruta de
nuestra ciudad realizamos un plantón
pacífico en el aeropuerto
si bien los resultados obtenidos no
fueron los óptimos al menos hemos
logrado que se mantenga un vuelo de esa
aerolínea
otra de las quejas era del sector
turístico por la falta de promoción de
nuestra ciudad en esta ocasión en
octubre de 2017 aprovechamos el poder de
las redes sociales y creamos una campaña
en facebook con el hashtag estaba por
vos cuenca abrimos una fanpage donde
publicamos fotos espectaculares de la
ciudad de cuenca las mismas que han
tenido un alcance de hasta 90 mil
personas entre 1000 y 2000 like y en
ocasiones hasta 900 veces compartidas
otro de los reclamos en nuestra ciudad
es el crecimiento de los niveles de
contaminación ambiental y la
deforestación tomando acción estos
reclamos realizamos siembras y al
momento hemos sembrado más de 1000
árboles
para que ustedes tengan una idea la
empresa de aseo de cuenca ingresa siete
veces al día al centro de nuestra ciudad
para mantener la zona céntrica de manera
impecable
tomando acción a esto con un grupo de
300 deportistas pusimos en práctica el
plugin cuenca
con el mensaje de que una ciudad limpia
no es la que se limpia sino la que no se
ensucia blogging significa correr y
recoger
esta es una iniciativa que nació en
suecia
y ahora se ha expandido en más de 100
países en ecuador fuimos los primeros y
semanas después lo replicó el municipio
de manta
con esta acción realizamos un vídeo lo
publicamos en facebook y en este momento
estamos en 15 países
hemos tenido un alcance de 538 mil
personas
definitivamente además de ser un buen
ejemplo ha sido una excelente promoción
para nuestra ciudad
hemos podido comprobar que existe una
gran predisposición de los ciudadanos de
hacer de una queja una acción concreta
son más de 2500 personas las que nos
hemos unido para realizar cada una de
estas actividades
a todos ellos les digo gracias por
sumarse por ser ejemplo y por demostrar
esas ganas de hacer una ciudad mejor
simplemente quejarse como he planteado
suele ser mal visto
sin embargo es claro que la queja es la
reacción individual aquello que no
percibimos bueno o adecuado para
nosotros o para los nuestros
pero tomando esa energía y gestionando
la de una manera diferente he podido
comprobar
que la queja
es un regalo y tú
qué estás haciendo con tus quejas
[Aplausos]